um
all right here we go
enchantrix hello i checked out your edit
and i i very much enjoyed it i didn't
realize it was on
your youtube at first i thought it was
maybe like an instagram or something but
i did check it out so hello hello
everybody
hello okay
let me check the sound here
cool yes all right we have uh
we have
i keep muting myself i'm sorry
hello i don't know why it keeps muting
me
we're not gonna touch it we're not gonna
touch it okay
[Laughter]
sorry i think we can hear me now when
this is green
we're good when it's red
apparently it's like some sort of a
touch thing
we'll leave it sorry i wasn't here last
week
um
i was very very
sick and i didn't actually even get home
until after the episode aired but we're
here this week
and we have three more episodes after
this
tell them mr anderson tell him tell him
tell him
do this all right i believe we are good
how has everybody been
what's up forsaken yo yo yo hello
everybody
i do get sick a lot i have a a very bad
immune system
um
part of a disorder i was born with but
hey
it is what it is
we don't let it hold us back huh
um
what is going on everybody
the episode drops i'm gonna say in
16 minutes
i'm gonna say the episode's going to be
dropping at 12 50 my time which would be
11 50 pacific time and 2 50 eastern time
if you're watching right now
on eastern time good for you true fans
true fans
i love it
love it love it love it welcome welcome
welcome everybody
i appreciate the get well soon yeah i'm
not a hundred percent better yet but uh
we're still kind of better let me pull
up disney plus here
making sure we
have everything
my microphone up here
just make sure
come on there you go
i locked into my like one of my disney
plus accounts because you know you how
you can have multiple profiles the other
day and i was like trying to watch moon
night episode two and i couldn't find it
and i guess there was parental settings
on it and this is kind of ranked in the
pg 16 17 something like that
um i prefer i see i see a few people
asking me if i prefer mr knight or moon
knight i definitely prefer midnight
so i want to test something out
if i play this can you all
oh well you can obviously hear that it's
coming from my speakers
[Music]
get it out of here
can you hear it
you can't hear that but if i turn that
off
you can't hear it cool because if i'm
not mistaken
let me see here uh
that's not it
yeah
i'm playing midnight episode 2 right now
and you can't see anything it's just a
black screen
which they uh
they changed that so
huh
hey i love the mr knight costume as well
i'm not saying i don't like it i just
think the moon night costume is pretty
cool
they're both really cool and you'll see
both again tonight um i think this one
out of all the episodes has
the most
uh definitely the coolest action
i don't know if i could say the most
action actually yeah i probably like the
most action yeah
yeah i used to be able to like you know
give y'all like little flat wrong screen
give you a little flashes of like what
was happening
but now disney plus figured something
out to where
if you try to str like screen recorder
or anything like that they uh
yeah it's just
it's completely blank
hello hello hello hello hello
spectacular i saw that comment about
jake i have a theory about that
i have a theory about that
all right so this is working
um where have i seen up to i have seen
up to episode four so i have not seen
five or six
and four ends uh
i won't say anything i was going to try
to i don't think it's a spoiler but some
people might say
say it's a spoiler
it's
like it really makes you
go whoa like what's happening like
that's all i can say because that's what
i think that's what this uh i think
that's what
the last couple episodes did i think
they made you think like you know is it
crazy like is he actually crazy
or
is it real right which i think episode
two was more along the lines of like
yeah it's real just because you know
people can't see it doesn't mean it's
not real clearly there's some you have
to have some type of like
godly touch to it right which uh harrow
has because he's omits avatar and uh
mark steven does
excuse me
so yeah
welcome welcome welcome
uh do anything about do i know anything
mando's culture about who saw the five
leaks so
i don't know how true this is
because i'm on the press list this is
how i get to see everything right i uh
for disney i'm i'm i'm marked as an
influencer and a press
someone who uh you know report some
things for them and stuff like that so
um i i get these screeners and i get
invited to the premieres and stuff um
i did not get episode five i got
episodes one through four
um
but rumor has it some got five
uh
i don't i don't know how true that is i
don't know anyone personally that that
has gotten episode five
um
but apparently some did
and some people were saying
some people were saying episode four was
their favorite until they saw episode
five
i i don't know haven't seen episode five
um and i won't spoil anything about
episode four all i can say is i do think
three
is better than the first and the second
one and i
i think i enjoyed the second one more
than the first as well some people were
like oh you said you know you said two
was better than one and it wasn't it's
like i'm sorry you didn't think so i i
thought it was
guys if you spam you're gonna get you're
gonna get timed out
aloha warren red room trainer playhead
aloha back to you question midnight gets
second season which villain would you
like to see mark go up against person
who like to punish her that would be
really cool i'd really like dracula and
yo check this out let's talk about this
let's talk about this
i don't know if you saw
um
how would i bring this up
how would i bring this up on on the
stream i think there's a way hold on let
me try i don't know if y'all saw
ethan hawk's interview i think it was
jimmy fallon let's check that out ethan
hawk
not hawkeye
jimmy fallon
is he i wonder if it'll show
yeah yeah moon knight fan theories all
right so let me try to find this because
this theory is actually like
really cool and it made me think like
what like
i know i have it on my phone somewhere
hold on
they hit me with that 15 second ad all
right hold on
all right so check this out check this
out let's watch this let's watch this
everybody check this out i one of these
theories like kind of blew my mind hold
on let me unmute it everybody should be
able to hear this
uh
all right so so listen
uh ismail montoya any first appearances
in episode three um i mean yes because
they introduce new people anyone
significant i won't say
maybe yes maybe no
i don't want to spoil it either answer
is a spoiler i've learned now to not
really answer these um
so i just i can't say i appreciate the
super chat um
i mean new people are in it right they
go to new places and stuff is anyone
significant
we'll see but check check this out guys
check this theory out and how ethan hawk
responds to it i want to know what you
guys think but here you go and there are
already fan theories about your
character and i thought maybe you could
either debunk them or maybe hint right
here we go this kid actually
is right in trouble all right i signed
an nda but
there is a uh
there's a fan theory that the hulk will
appear in moon night
that would be cool right that would be
cool except i know mark ruffalo and i
think if we were in the same show he
would have wait is the episode out
are you guys for reals
nope not out for me
all right continue this can y'all hear
this can we can we hear this
hey bradley jones thank you appreciate
that
can't oh that is so loud i turned up my
headset ritwick hey what's going on man
thanks for the super chat we're doing
well thank you a chance that events
haven't been pre-snapping you know
i don't know we'll have to uh
we'll have to see about that i enjoy
those theories that talk about you know
pre-snap and
you know he he maybe he comes back and
that's how he he's kind of sharing this
body i i enjoy those theories i i think
this
i don't know if it takes place before or
after the snap i really don't but
um i don't think they would like
say like oh that's why he's got like
this mental disorder
but we'll see you never know all right
you can hear it cool
there we go
or something so i don't think that one's
got a lot of legs all right so that was
hulk whatever but they're going over
theories ethan hawt's reacting all right
so check this out
spiderman stuff that's right exactly we
did yeah all right there's a fan theory
that blade will appear in blade
oh stop now you're playing with it now
you're playing now you're just playing
with me
yeah would you got a text from blade
yeah i don't know i don't know
i wish blade was there i would have been
cool okay
is this here this theory this theory
this is my favorite fan theory this one
says since not a lot is known about your
character arthur harrow
some fans speculate that arthur harrow
is a decoy name and you're actually
playing the villain dracula
that is awesome
i so want that to be true i mean i
but your expectation is so intense i
want to say yes so bad i am dracula oh
wow
the hell with the lawyers
dracula
all right
so all right so that one all right good
yeah that's your doctor
dracula so bad okay
marvel watches
yeah so dracula we can make so i think
that would be just like the coolest
thing ever like if he was dracula like
that would be
that would be so cool man like that
would be so cool
if he like just ended up being dracula's
on their time forsaken thanks for
receiving we try to have to do that we
talk all the time
uh my favorite disney plush show so far
is loki
uh
i haven't seen the final episodes of
moon knight they could change that like
i really like midnight a lot
it's probably my second or third
definitely loki and one division like
they're up there
um for sure thanks for that super chat
bud
but isn't that cool like that could
totally be real and they could just be
like why don't you go ahead and act
like
that
like
be like oh you wish it was real and blah
blah blah kind of tease them a little
bit but then it's going to be real and
then i can expect it's real because you
already kind of fake admitted it i think
that would be
so funny so clever i i just i think but
that's i think that would be it like
he's dracula i think he'd be really
really cool
really really really really cool really
cool yeah that's what i'm saying uh
diller imagine if that's true like
that'd be so crazy if they like really
gave it to us like that my jacket keeps
like coming up
all right let's
stop let's check
no i'm guessing in four more minutes
four minutes and it's gonna be up
yeah
excuse me guys still a little sick i'm
sorry for keep
keep coming yeah i didn't uh
zero [ __ ] i'm waiting for duchamp to
come wait and wait and wait oh did i
miss the super chat
it says dallas bonillas donated two
dollars to super chat i'm so sorry i
don't i don't see it
hmm
courtesy vampire what's up what's going
good to see you again thanks for super
chat yeah that would be really cool if
he was playing a combination of the sun
king in him
you're on professional real rejects get
out of here
do your own live stream
go
hi greg how's it going
love and miss you
uh let me find that super chat so sorry
let me uh
i know where to find it
dallas for news warning you go doctor
strange premiere i am i got invited
yesterday actually found it it didn't
show up on my
my comments over here
uh dallas
bonilla so apologize about that but i
got you here uh yes i am i'm going to
the doctor strange premiere um very
excited about that
um
apparently the cast is
big
[Laughter]
yeah jonathan cahoon what is up a member
of the channel thank you so much for
being a member uh
i'm so sorry
am i a stranger thanks for i am and i
did see the trailer today and it looks
pretty freaking cool and that new
villain looks uh scary and intense and
uh
yeah
um
you're going to the strange premiere
says the person who texted me hey man
did you get the invite i just got the
invite
[Laughter]
don't try to fool people
everyone drink your g fuel
use code cosmic if you order g phil
online
boom boom
where's the doctor strange premier it's
in la
they're all in well i guess
i guess they randomly do some in new
york but
that's typically like like like
okay so i figured out if i move this
it mutes it i don't really like that i
mean it has a button under here but now
if i move it
why
why
all right i think it is out and hi sue
how's it going um
i'm all right today uh i'm better than
last week but still a little sick
unfortunately
uh yeah for a second i'm actually
um getting a place in la hopefully
pretty soon
um i own a house here in utah so i'm not
going to just completely move but uh
but yeah i i am probably getting a place
out there in ollie soon i can't really
disclose too much of that
but um
it'll be a cool situation
when and hope hopefully when it happens
uh for those asking when it's out
i think it's out now it's 12 50. they
usually drop them 10 minutes before
and look at that episode three right on
the dot 12.50
oh i gotta get a
timer up
or is it a stopwatch stopwatch that's
what i use all right we are about to
start this mr anderson are you ready
i'm gonna assume you're ready because
you've been timing people out and stuff
uh forsaken you're in here as well
it is indeed all right we're
gonna start this in
five four
three two one
hit
oh i didn't start the stopwatch
it must be very difficult having all
those voices said one hit i don't expect
him no i'm not going to be able to play
the
music unfortunately
so right pc streaming
nope
that's not gonna work i didn't think
this through oh well
you know what i can just use my phone
to monitor chat
hey
fat man
oh you're in florida nice that's where
i'm from i was born in pensacola and
grew up in orlando
thanks to super chat
56 yeah
what's up underserved
i'm excited for y'all to see this
episode i really am
is everything
okay yeah we're good
all right here we go
of course he is
it's funny that i that i because i
figure there are like real people out
here who do this stuff like create fake
ids and stuff like you know they're out
there somewhere
hey gaming vibes
what's up sparky please ricky 246 full
what's going on
i really wish i could give you all flash
like the little flashes of the screen
like i used to but dang
like if i pull this here
what do you see just a black screen dang
it
i mean we're watching it but i'm not
showing it which is how i'm allowed
to watch it
i used to be able to show parts of it
but disney blocked that now
i looked for a lot of clues here when i
was doing my breakdown
and i'll have to look through more oh i
need to turn subtitles on
get some hints at some things
english
yeah enchantrex remember how he used to
be able to show some of the screen can't
do that anymore fortunately
i also really wonder who this is i
question if this is due champ because we
haven't seen do champ yet
there's the marvel credits
i actually really like this music
[Music]
and the desert excuse me
well tell them to hurry up enchantrex
uh aries bjork i don't think there was a
doom a doctor doomed to use some people
might think so
i don't think so
and now it points down
but is it that so is it that simple
oh that guy was the cop from the
oh and that was the girl
i love how she's like mark spencer's
striking us he's like i know
what did you expect
yeah sorry guys i wish i could oh this
part's so cool alright we're just gonna
watch this part
some big old knives
the little kid
i guess it's not a little kid he's
probably 18 or something
oh this part
i thought it
just gets rid of the kid
those dang reflections allowing them
back in
hmm
that part like
it's kind of funny to me
because obviously like they were just
trying to kill him and then he runs into
them again and they're like just let us
go man like
why would he just let you go
you weren't gonna let him go you're
gonna kill him
i do like the music it's pretty cool
music
the soundtrack is available by like
hollywood records i think it said
stephen just needs to stop
dead
i love the i love the violence
his legs broken
i guess you were wrong about that one
can't you
you guys listening to this part right
here
you guys listening to this part right
here that's
jake lockley that's all i'm gonna say
he's gotta be there somewhere
just risk the roth i love this part
healing armor
i like that line
i
any good ideas i have a bad one love it
oh yeah yeah
god of the moon
country's the god of the moon
i'm about to be called upon
this is so cool i love spark
a meeting of the iniad
this is really cool
love how excited he is
look how cool that is
i know it's not out for some people so
i'm gonna avoid like really saying some
things about the episode but
i
it's so cool
this whole scene right here i really
like
hot door
no i'm i'm not sponsored by adidas
jeremy
so cool
that's half or
this is
love it so cool
laughs
the might of gods
isn't it mr anderson it's super cool
so
i mean he knew he said what did he say
i'm about i'm about to be called upon
well that's rude he called him a
makeshift avatar
hmm
ashamed god
literally playing on his mental illness
cheap shop
wow
i really try to buy that
not sure i believe harrow
i actually think haro
has
like a mental illness as well
like clearly if he wants ahmed to like
you know kill all these people who will
sin and have it sin but i i think he has
some sort of mental illness as well
use your words
i just realized the irony here
i won't say it because i know some
people can't watch it right now who are
in the chat but
i just
realized a big irony there
that's funny
okay
hmm
did they just take the cups or they
it's got you
yeah i saw that guilford godfrey passed
away today that's sad very really really
sad
he's not the best at apologies is he
i do like that this is a
more mature
more mature show
mogart for the comic fans that name
should ring a bell
that name shouldn't ring a bell
hey thanks musa i appreciate that
yeah marcus it is a it is a more serious
show and i and i like that about it a
lot
i feel like
yeah
i do like
like
find it funny
that he just kind of like abandoned his
wife
like yeah i get it country wants her as
the next avatar and he wants to protect
her and everything but like
he could have told her
it's pretty close but loki's my favorite
show still
we'll see how it ends the ending will
the ending will judge
we'll judge the ending
hey channel the great
you get it you're a comic fan you know
it there you go
a lot of friends with a lot of gun
the name of episode 3 is the friendly
type
in the maldives
i wonder what this game's called he says
it here but i i don't i didn't have
subtitles like when they send it to us
to watch they don't have subtitles so i
didn't catch the name of it but they're
gonna say right here
what it's called
you guys hear that i'm not going to
spoil it for people who haven't seen it
but
you heard that that's a big easter egg
el mermah
elmer ma games
album
as an annual race organization
so what's really sad
is
this actor died
like a few months ago
in a in the ski
skiing accident
uh gaspard julio
leo french actor really sad
really sad that he died a few months ago
right after he got done with this
it is mr anderson you are right
well mr x hold tight in this episode
hold tight just a little bit
we'll type mr x
hey juan thanks for the sub uh it
started we're 27 minutes into it
fortunately disney blocks me from
showing it it's just like a black screen
right here some of you guys can see this
in the timer just a black screen
if i could show it i would i'm sorry
it's so nice having subtitles
coded
oh thank you one i appreciate that
i'm not promising like gore mr x but
there's some cool stuff
he's praying
i wonder what those masks are in the
background
cartonage that's what it is
nah i feel you enchantrix i feel you
i prefer three antelope i prefer this
episode
it's the best so far
she called him mark
speaking arabic i thought he spoke
oh thank you amuse i appreciate that
the treasure
no thank you kumar appreciate that
marcus staying arthur everywhere
that just looks like the power stone to
me
like it's made of the power stone
what time is it in america it is 1 22 am
hey antonio i appreciate that thank you
summon the suit
i wish they told us what he was saying
where do you live
yeah sorry here we go
moon night
look at that
oh thank you earl clearance
love that
crescent darts
ah nice new zealand
no capes that's why you have no cabs
i do love the game mr anderson
but people always want to grab the
heroes by the capes
i am going to the premier yes
broken arm boom broken leg
[Laughter]
chill the f out
oh love that
oh
stabby stab stab
yes i do musa
crescent
what did you think mr x
you like that scene i think that scene
was freaking awesome it's an awesome
scene
awesome soon
the endings of this episode is really
good too
definitely prefer marvel
wasn't that good uh anthony all right
take the money mark take the water
question
yeah it wasn't that was a great battle
loved it
how much time left probably like
10 minutes
probably a little less because uh
it's a 15 minute episode
but you know how long the credits are so
i'd say about like nine minutes left
these are always being followed they
need to like learn how to lose a tail
oh thanks aaron appreciate that i try
not to like
say too much because i know some people
are in the chat who like can't watch it
while we watch it so i try not to be too
spoiler otherwise i'd just be spitting
out a bunch of different things because
i've already done my breakdown on this
episode because marvel sent me the first
four episodes
this part's pretty cool though
huh
that would be pretty cool in a red
i
appreciate that aaron
hope you continue enjoy
nah thanks marcus appreciate that and
i'll be coming out
tomorrow well today technically
cheers thanks a lot
uh kamar i i don't know about that not
sure at all
i love how steven learned like
everything that he knows just by trying
to stay awake at night
like he studied you know ancient
egyptian hieroglyphics like
constellations all the stuff like just
egyptians invented modern everyday he
learned this by trying to stay up at
night
it's french
most people know that mark or steven
that's confusing geez
even in my breakdowns like he like i'll
catch myself be like and stephen oh wait
no that was mark that did that
unfortunately it's not that simple
stephen is pretty great i love steven
unless we know exactly what the sky
looked like on that date
i remember every night
this is so cool
such a sad line right there
this is so cool
this is mental
everyone else can see it too
and that's the problem
that's what he was told not to do
surprisingly painful
chanting and coptic
no
culture
dang
i don't think this is going to mess up
the timeline
see ya muza have a good time
gods are a little sus to me
some of them
you
you suck caro
i was thinking the same thing mr
anderson
don't touch him
rude
he technically is an avatar he's an
avatar for amit
your torment forged me
i owe my victory to you
there you go
episode three i personally think that's
the best episode so far
what do you what do you all think i i i
definitely think that's the best episode
so far
there is no post credit trust me
i've searched
let's do discord
[Music]
discord
right marcus i i definitely think it was
the best episode yet
i i for sure like that episode the most
so far
i
i don't know if i like it
i don't know if i like it more or less
than episode four
the only thing episode four once
it's pretty episode four reminds me of
indiana jones
alrighty
uh episode three is out we just watched
it yeah
uh i don't
uh
contract simon marvel i mean i sign like
ndas and contracts when i go to like
premieres and stuff obviously they make
you sign things that's like you know you
won't do spoilers and you won't show
like when i get sent all these episodes
one my name is like watermarked right on
it so i'm like staring at my name and
holding their time but they obviously
make you sign stuff then right you know
not allowed to do this if you do it you
get sued blah blah blah
so yeah but besides i know there i don't
have like
i'm just considered press and considered
an influencer
who's on there
pressless
jonathan enjoyed episode two more
yeah um you're gonna run into that a
little bit more jonathan that that
storyline um to be fair just part of the
origin
but
yeah
uh rich tang i don't know but i i do
believe you know they hinted at him
pretty pretty heavy this time pretty
in a pretty big way yeah the watermark
is like right on the screen the entire
time and
yeah
yeah jake was very very
very much implied in this episode hi
chris
i know right oh you haven't seen that
one
voice and video
so you're saying i can switch my camera
input
i've tried it before what
huh
are you there
i don't hear chris anymore
chris
oh you can't hear me
you can't hear me oh no
oh
we're working on it input
input device
it says you should be able to hear me
christopher
hello
hello
let's try this
why can't he hear me that doesn't make
any sense
can you can y'all i guess y'all can't
even hear
chris right now can you
i'm trying to get him in
grass
chris
hello no he can't hear me
why can't he hear me
voice and video input
check
check yeah it says you should be able to
hear me
weird i don't know what to do
do they change the origin jake
who's the real antagonist of the show i
mean i think it's gonna be ahmed
what is happening what
looks like another voice channel you
want to switch to two
yeah how do you hear me trying to talk
yes i can
i can hear you chris yes i can
hello
no hello
[Music]
hello hi
there you go okay
we were working on that for a while talk
so i can okay
people should be able to hear you now
yeah yeah yeah i yeah i definitely can't
switch my
video input i just tried it
that's weird you have to deactivate it
from
stream lives this way but that's okay i
guess
okay so you didn't see the third episode
what do you think of the third episode
oh i very much enjoyed it i had seen it
but i very much enjoyed it i think it
was the best episode
you think it's the best one so far it's
a different tone it's slower
um i didn't think it was slower i
thought it was more than the other ones
yeah because they like they're giving us
a lot of information which i feel like
can slow it down a little bit i think
they had like they had that whole fight
in the beginning and where he's like
stabbing people
like actually stabbing people and then
there's definitely some intense seats
for sure and then the moon night scene
was more than we've got because in the
first episode moon knight's only in it
at the very very end
and then
in the second episode he's in it for a
little bit but it's more like a funny
scene than it is like an action scene
this one is like getting stabbed and
stabbing people oh yeah no that that
ending fight
this one it had the gods i heard you say
something about bass bass statue was
definitely in there
that statue they were asking me which
avatar was back no no the avatar was
they announced everybody that was their
present yeah and he wasn't he wasn't
there yeah he wasn't there
so all right everyone rate the episode
what did we do last time not one through
ten
a plus to f minus no yeah
everyone wrote the episode between a
plus and a minus you have three choices
bradley johnson's super chat when they
mentioned magiport was that a reference
to the falconer soldier absolutely
absolutely
uh jonathan cahoon yeah i agree this
does feel more like the marvel netflix
shows than it does like the disney plush
shows it's definitely darker it's
definitely
i think meant for
more mature audiences they say the s
word so much i love it
and at one point he's like let's chill
the f out
[Laughter]
take the bunny back right i wonder if
they're sitting there like how many
f-bombs do we get how many one none
[Laughter]
not an overwhelming amount of bees
i have only a's at the moment i got a g
plus from daniel gary here i'm not a g
plus
oh one b plus uh ismail montoya was that
a wakanda avatar no i know you're
talking about she is the avatar for
i have it in my notes here from doing my
breakdown
i read out the entire breakdown
i just gotta record it now
uh all right who was that that is
hathor
or
music wasn't it yeah
love of music remember the name hawthor
hawthorne
yeah
goddess of love yeah that's how i have
my notes here
half haththor hawthor hathor
yeah
and i think that like they
punch you in uh thor might have been
like lovers or something like that it
certainly seemed that way didn't it
i think there was something interesting
to take away from that whole council
part like you were mentioning the statue
of bastard was there
like basta isn't an egyptian god
in
marvel comics is that's fair and marvel
comics she's not but or they're not but
let's assume
that they still aren't
that does show that the egyptian gods
and other gods do counsel together
potentially yeah and if you if you
noticed actually
so here's my deal i'm trying to burp but
i can't
here's my deal like
the gods at least some of them seem a
little sus to me because i'm like
you didn't investigate
anything right like you're just sitting
there like so easy to find right
you don't just want to like maybe scan
the desert a little bit to find these
thousands of people digging
right exactly it's like you you don't
you know you know you're not gonna dig a
little bit like
a little bit
right
and that's pretty much all it was it was
like nah screw you can't you you're
you've been
causing problems for us we don't really
want to listen to you
and then at the end they just like let
arthur in like oh yeah go ahead talk to
the statue grab it
technically an avatar for anybody so why
don't you come in and talk i hear people
saying that but isn't he ahmed's avatar
he's ahmed's avatar he he's not there as
ahmed's avatar because the whole
argument was that he wasn't trying to
free on it
that's true i guess yeah but he is but
he is ahmed's avatar he's trying to i
think he's trying to i think he's no
he's mentioned that because he said that
the staff was a gift to ahmet's first
avatar doesn't necessarily say he's the
first avatar but now he has it so i want
to assume he's avatar because he has her
power i mean he obviously isn't commune
with her right because he has her power
so i would assume moon knight gets the
costume he gets the
power stone stuff it looks like a power
stone
yeah
looks like the power supply definitely
yeah the leader of god
god stuff going on right before thor
eleven thunder yeah right um
someone just mentioned yeah the leader
god seems sus that was osiris it does
seem kind of sus
like seriously just like you're not
going to investigate anything at all
nothing nothing at all like just go look
at the desert real quick
you know just a tiny tiny little bit so
about the woman helping layla in the
beginning
i think that might be duchamp i think
they might change that character
completely from the comics
i don't know because the story is
already like a little weird me i'm
thinking maybe bushman
did kill
mark and the father but he's just not
gonna be like a very prominent character
they're gonna try to make it seem like
mark killed her but really it was you
know this other mercenary named bushman
that i was working with and blah blah
blah blah so i think he'll drop the name
but he won't be like
anything major like he was to moon in
the
comics yeah i wonder i wonder a lot of
those those connections that they're
gonna do and that's the fun about the
shows versus the
the comics and what we already know
about the character one moon knight
still has a lot of story to be told even
from what we have in the comics but then
on top of that now in the series
you know marvel can go whatever
direction they want they can change
anything they want stuff like these
details you're pulling out now like you
see a character like that character
could actually end up being something
important right later on so yeah rip to
get sparred you julio
who played uh
oh yes yes midnight man is his name in
the comics midnight man didn't seem to
be
as prominent of a role as in the comics
but definitely yeah
yeah uh john martinez thanks for super
chat uh we'll see
we'll see about that if professor x gets
killed in in the movie tahun sinha
thanks for super chat
what was that magical reference about i
just think that she's dealt
you know she stated in the beginning
that like um
she's stolen artifacts and stuff before
and she's
kept some to pay the bills which
obviously means she sold them so and you
know a lot all that criminal activity
goes down to major poor right so if you
steal like a famous egyptian artifact
that like the cops are going to be
looking for how you going to sell that
you're going to go to magic boy
right so uh does she know sharon carter
does she know the power broker who knows
you know like i'll say the first the
first real connection to the mcu
yeah pretty much
like there that's been completely
disconnected up until that that
reference yeah such a light and subtle
reference didn't really mean much i
don't think other than hey look
magipore's still there in this same
world like keep that in mind guys yeah
little remember
oh for sure for sure i definitely
don't think it means anything for
midnight but maybe they connect other
things down the road
oh of course and i think moon knight
inevitably ends up being connected to
mcu like there's no world that doesn't
oh no i mean it already technically like
what you said right there it just got
connected well here's a here's a good
question i want to answer because it's
just a good question where did it go
oh
no i just saw it where did it go
uh jay
consiglio conqui gone does that mean his
power is gone yes because there's
there's a specific scene where conscious
hey look at sally cat
oh bye cat oh no bye we don't have a way
for her to hear us and we have one
camera yeah i gotcha we need to get
another camera and she can join discord
upstairs super chat love you guys and
keep killing it the gods are being
manipulated
thank you jake
yeah but to go back to
that concho made it very clear
before he
made an eclipse
he was like the last time
yeah he's like
what's the worst that could happen he's
like they you know
would turn me into stone and mark's like
i could think of worse things and he's
like oh yeah try fighting everybody when
you don't have yeah without my suit
right exactly so it's i thought it was
cool right definitely got a showcase of
a lot of what the suit does right
i mean he got stabbed so many times he
blocked bullets we saw the crescent
darts
yeah right we saw the crescent darts
come out we saw the the crescent cape
the crescent cape was busted out
that was really cool the crescent busted
out escaped during that fight scene and
i was like
no kick that's what i said too knock it
okay yeah
anytime there's a superhero who gets
grabbed by the cape no games at any time
yeah i i'm thinking like
i'm thinking the scene where they
bust out conscious gonna be pretty epic
oh yeah i mean he literally said to
stephen
tell mark to save me yeah get me out to
set me free yeah
yeah what happens you just break it
um
i don't know i thought we got the best
fight scenes in this one i thought it
was actually cool like we literally saw
him like stabbing people
oh no blood on the knives and it's not
like super gory but i i do think it's
it's more violent than we what we do
yeah i watch stuff outside of the mcu
obviously so you and everybody else so
like compared to that it's still very
mild mannered so it's hard to like
remember like hey this is actually the
mcu like
this is kind of intense for the mcu but
when you compare it to like other things
like just even peacemaker like
that's a whole different type of thing
but this is marvel this is disney it's
literally on disney plus so it's kind of
crazy to see that transition and that's
like kind of bodes well for the future
with deadpool coming and oh for sure
midnight sons and stuff like that well
and um
i told the story like pre-chat so i'm
pretty sure only some people heard it at
this point um
excuse me um
i like how you know you know how like on
disney plus you can have like multiple
accounts
yeah so i guess i had like one set up on
my
ipad that was like on a different
profile
and i was it was funny because like i
logged on
and i was like gonna watch a moon night
episode just to recap and then i was
like i don't see moon night why is it
not like front row center like it's one
of disney places like brand new shows
then i clicked on marvel and i couldn't
find it like what's going on so the
parental settings
i had wouldn't show it
oh because because it's like pg-16 or
something like that and i only had it to
like pg-13 so i couldn't see it so i had
to change them so they definitely have
changed their parents settings
yeah wow yeah that's that's awesome
though right that's gonna work out is it
good for deadpool and
yeah which means we can still get it
yeah tal zanko thanks for super chat
we're gonna see jacob come out i think
we saw well we didn't see jake come out
but when
when mark is like what the hell are you
doing steven stevens like i didn't do
this mark's like i didn't do this i
think that was jake
yeah yeah it's gotta be right it's it
should i mean i don't know what else it
would be
it's definitely interesting
kanchu has a third secret personality
that he's kept secret from mark to yeah
right
mark ain't doing it because mark's kind
of hesitant because of stephen stephens
kind of getting to mark
steven took over the body a lot right
but i feel like mark wouldn't
necessarily
do a lot of like hesitating to kill
people like the whole part at the end
when they're having a big fight scene
he's like a little hesitant yeah to the
point that stephen could come out and
take over the body right and that's his
hesitation like yeah i really shouldn't
just be killing all these people because
some pigeon man told me to
and uh maybe that's why we're starting
to get that third personality i was
conscious like oh my gosh come on now
well it went away real quick once uh
take the money back yeah that that was
good yeah but once uh layla was in
trouble that came out real quick
everything he got stabbed with he used
to stab other people that was awesome
right magic imagine that you're like
stabbing someone next thing you know
they're ripping it out of their body and
stabbing you and you're dead
i would have given up a long time ago
when he was stabbed the fourth time and
it didn't stop him yeah right i'm out
obviously
chill the f out
it was kind of cool
to see kanchu finally being nice to
stephen
yeah at the very end he even threw
another dig he's like i some of the gods
and used them in the world
but then he could see like i think
steven's knowledge really because he was
figuring it all out well and to me
sorry
i was just going to say and it was
really really cool just to see that
because i think everybody has a really
emotional connection to stephen
obviously down on his left
guy
it's cool to see him kind of come up and
conscious kind of be like wow you are
useful and all i kept thinking the whole
time is it's like a lego video game
you know where like different characters
can do different things
like marks your fighters right right
right yeah and you have to like change
to that character in the lego game to do
that
yeah um it was super cool to see that
and then of course the incredible
visuals
at the very end there yeah it was super
cool
and uh
you
you sense like a bit of sadness and
conscious because she's like i remember
that night it's like i remember every
night almost like i'm cursed to be a god
you know what i mean like oh yeah um but
actually what i think was shown in this
episode
was that
because there's a lot of like there's
there's a lot of crap talked about
konchu i think like
in this all of this you know
no i think just from the the series like
mark doesn't want to be his avatar right
right but he's sitting there like oh
guess what i'm going to grab your wife
you know what i mean like right i'm
going to make her my
crap right and he's talking crap to
stephen all the stuff but and this one
he you know he made the sacrifice for
you know to save humanity essentially
right so it's just like okay
yeah you might pry on the weak-minded
people but i guess you are i guess in
the end you're doing it for you know
yeah i was gonna say arthur does have a
pretty solid argument there in the
council like
arthur's mentally unstable as well i
mean obviously is to to because you
wanted him right well not only that but
he has to be to try to resurrect a god
who wants to kill people way before they
do anything a murder guy yeah hero's
playbook um heard some things about
episode 4 can you rate the ending
so hesitant
uh because i don't want any spoilers at
all it's hard sometimes too yeah um
it's cool
it's cool it's
like it's good every episode's gotten
better so far that's what i'll say yeah
i
it's just it's been just straight uphill
for me it's been fantastic yeah um i uh
confused confusing confusing that's
that's
yeah i guess you asked me to rate it
though
like an eight
a minus a plus we made them change you
have to change two a minus b plus b plus
b plus
yeah there we go
so uh oh i have followed through and
brought something different and have
totally nailed it this takes my top spot
honestly that's that's a cool way to
like put it though like it is something
different and they have completely
nailed it but i feel like every disney
plus show we've gotten so far
has been very unique from the norm and
from each other
i think of
one division
and located completely different things
yeah but and they were also kind of
similar but they were executed
differently
uh because they're kind of mystical
but like low-key with the variance and
with like the tv yeah you know there's
so much school stuff and then one of
what the dark hold and
you know the the reality she created
like the tv shows and it was really
really cool and then you know falcon in
the winter soldier was very different it
was very grounded
uh which it was
classic marvel i suppose right and then
hawkeye was meant to be like the comedy
right where it's like oh let's introduce
like you know this new character and
stuff like that it's not as serious
um but had something like behind the
scenes of
right right
average day of being an avenger which
was kind of fun to see too
yeah um james o'rourke
thanks for the super chat did either of
you think the episode was a flashback at
first like me uh
i don't think i did did yours
wasn't
i i could have i could see how it might
have come off that oh for sure but yeah
i don't think i was trying to figure out
what's going on it kind of just started
and i was like uh uh
yeah what's going on what's going on
what's going on you gotta keep in mind
that like chris and i are
this is our job we're like in this we
research stuff all the time
so the second stuff starts we're just
like all right what's really going on
here so we look pretty deep into things
although i would say like thinking it's
a flashback it's looking pretty deep
into things as well so i like how you
think
yeah definitely not bad israel thanks
for super chat
if conscious gone arthur lucius's
scepter powers
no because he doesn't get his powers
from country the scepter is from
ahmed
so
yeah unrelated power i am curious though
and it definitely needs to be talked
about i guess
the dissecting of the gods and i think
with thor love and thunder gore the god
butcher come in
you know the rumors of bass like this is
definitely a direction marvel's heading
right now is you know
mcu gods
and and it's it's cooler than not cooler
than it's cool that it's different than
like the cosmic gods like because
different than celestials and the
turtles it's different than thor it's
like
but but how different is it than thor
because you know thor's north mythology
does thor maybe know these gods is this
like yeah i mean it's odd yeah hard
right like egyptology and and north
mythology
i mean where's hercules going to show
like these are all people who you would
like zeus would be equal to
you know osiris for me well they are
they do kind of cross paths in the
comics and right yeah and then but you
have different levels of like
maybe not so much in the mcu
but like at some point in time some of
the ined gods are like oh that like the
celestials are coming back to judge
earth and probably kill earth what do we
do we need to save earth and it's kind
of like okay two different gods
kind of going at each other there
there's a lot of cool stuff
in some weird passovers it's like
did odin disagree with horus when they
said we're not gonna be involved with
man and he just went off and controlled
all nine realms because like that's an
even god level in my mind
like horus and and odin are like equals
yeah uh i don't know because i don't
know how deep they're gonna get into
that even but there's something there i
feel well in the comics they
um it's interesting because what did
well kanchu as mark said like
you need to like
something along the lines of like pay
more attention to this realm
and be it's because and you know that's
why they have avatars because none of
them can actually be there that's why
when conscious was walking away mark was
like aren't you gonna
come and he's like oh i'll be there he's
like i just have to be there through you
like
yeah the reason no one else can see me
but you because i'm not actually there
something specific to like the outer
void or wherever right so
in the comics they live in a place
called the celeb it's called celestial
he
oh i don't know the heliotopia something
like that hellotopia something like that
yeah i don't know how to exactly
pronounce that referring i think so i
think that's the realm that they live in
the outer void or whatever because at
some point they all got together and
said hey
earth needs to do its own thing we built
the pyramids we gave the egyptians all
this technology and stuff we need to not
be involved right left
well it sounds like the humans
turned on them
because that's what he said he's like
we're gonna ban humanity humanity
abandoned us that's fair that's very
fair so they're like you know what peace
do yourself we're gods
and then maybe odin would love to
protect the nine realms and blast just
when did you know the wakanda thing and
who knows what other gods are going to
introduce if we get some greek mythology
in there well that's another like you're
headed in that direction well that's
another point you bring up because you
know there's clearly a statue of bast
there the black panther god but the
avatar wasn't there what was the avatar
doing who is the avatar will we see that
in wakanda forever
were all gods at one point egyptian gods
and then they just all went their own
way right maybe who knows you know i and
they can do anything that was why i was
saying or you were one of us was saying
i can't remember so early um
like marvel can do whatever they want at
this point really like guess what the
comics their guideline but i think more
phase four than even the infinity saga
they're really going to start
introducing their own personal thoughts
now
and a little bit less of hey this is
what happened in this comic book
yeah and what's interesting is another
reason i think the gods are kind of sus
is because i think there was a scene
where i thought i had saw i thought i i
saw like a bunch of other statues
and then at the end what does he he says
something like
he's tethered to this place here i have
the scene right here hold on
he says
he's tethered to this place now like
many before him so i'm like what are
y'all doing just turn all these gods to
stones like are they all
like
coming up against you and rebelling like
what like right so there's this council
here right
and they decide who's right and who's
wrong right ahmet was a god and they
said hey we don't like what you're doing
whether they were right or wrong they
get the final say and they just
so how many other gods are there and
will they all be freed at some point are
we going to get like god wars i think so
i think we should because he's super
cool because kanchu at one point in time
thanks for reminding me mr anderson
he said that he disagreed with the gods
of abandoning humanity so it's like okay
is that why you got banished the other
guys were like we'll screw you for like
liking humanity
yeah like a little sus
stop praying to us and
egypt well
in some
i don't know if it's actual
in the actual mythos but isn't it like
um
like clash of the titans that like the
gods get their powers from humans
praying to them
isn't it something like that
i i do remember like oh yeah yeah in one
of them it's like no and one of them it
was like don't pray to ares that'll
summon him
i knew that much but i think there was
something about
i don't know if it gives him power
something like that but i definitely
don't think that's how it is in the mcu
i just wonder if that's in completely
unrelated news the little boy from adam
project is going to be percy jackson
oh cool in the series
yeah that's a good pick
i like it i like it he did a really good
job
completely unrelated news but hey
uh
vexter 76
didn't get some episode confused hit me
with some questions
uh but it does you know while we're
sitting here while i'm waiting for him
to type up your question it does beg for
me the question
because of the prominent influence that
gods are probably going to play in thor
you know
will we have a connecting piece here
come the end is this why we haven't
gotten the trailer yet because we have
to get to a certain moon night episode
that kind of introduces the gods before
we get something in the trailer they'll
give it away well it's not episode four
i'll tell you that much so i hope i
don't know i really i really hope we
don't have to wait for i don't want to
wait till five
but i mean but it is a it is something
that you know
yeah you got gore the god go or the god
butcher yeah and we've got tons of
rumors that we're going to actually be
seeing him going on tour and i say that
meaning attacking and trying to kill
gods
um
maybe this council's aware of that maybe
this has some type of connection
especially since they are
aware of other gods that aren't just
egypt gods so i don't know a lot of
interesting points came out of this
episode
yeah i like the council of the gods i
thought it was really cool
yeah i thought that was awesome yeah a
lot of fun
yeah uh i don't think bruce banner is
going to be making an appearance uh
explain the episode rexter um
tomorrow
i'm gonna do my full breakdown tomorrow
yeah i mean look out for my birthday
that's a lot i mean i uh so basically i
did a different breakdown this time i
just summed it up into points
and i have
35 points episode walk through yeah
i mean it is a walk through but i does
it go in order question it does
no it does
um just out of curiosity why do you have
to edit it or something
uh i said in today's stream almost every
time i go live somebody comes in and
they like reference one of your videos
to me like hey warren talked about this
and then like explain it to me it's like
i'm like guys
i know
you know the guy in youtube that always
shows up and is like first yeah no i'm
[Music]
um
i was gonna say something i
oh i forgot
this episode got me excited
this is my favorite episode so far i'm
around because i actually so i didn't
watch the third one warren you watched
all four before we went to the premiere
right yeah
i watched i didn't have them yet so i
only when we went to the premiere they
showed us the first two right and then
like a couple days after i came home i
got the other ones
so i had seen the first two i re-watched
those and then watched the third and
this one just got me really excited for
the prospect of moon knight it really
kind of brought it all together to the
marvel sphere
and and that's really what we start
feeling is that excitement that you get
from new marvel projects for me
yeah for sure um
i'm trying to think of episode four
they all kind of merge together in my
head so yeah really careful what i'm
saying so i will say
it's late and i don't want to miss it
this is what i'll say about episode four
it reminds me of indiana jones
whereas i think i've been like the first
episode definitely was like the mummy
like
the scarab and everything it's like i'm
like okay it's it's the mummy and now
like episode 4 i'm like indiana jones
for sure like
it's really cool and then i okay here's
what i will say
episode 4 takes a weird turn at some
point and you're like what
it will be a confusing one i think for a
lot of people too yeah and it makes you
just go like what has
really happened it's been fun
what what is happening and it's i think
a lot of people are going to be like
what the hell at the end
chill the f out
i love how he does that
take the body take the body mark take
the money take it back take it back
stephen grant's freedom
at some point he gets on board though
like really get on board steven yeah
like
up to this point up until like the very
first episode he's still trying to go
home
he's still trying to get to the airport
he's still trying to yell at at mark
like i hope at some point they just
truly become like buddies well it makes
breaking up together what makes you
wonder how is it going to end who gets
the body are they going to share it
forever share it forever
or do they lose mood night and we get
them back later like
there's a lot of possibilities for the
ending of this one it can either be
really good or really bad to be honest
maybe mark steven dies again and
conscious like i'm gonna bring you back
again and be my avatar again and
next thing you know
even more than mark and stephen i hope
conscious able to appreciate both of
them and and not be such a
jerk yeah i mean it was only because of
steven's knowledge that i find so funny
that he
learned by trying to stay up at night to
keep
not knowingly but trying to keep mark
away
howie
so like mark kind or he like kind of
learned it because of mark
right which is funny they used each
other in many ways all three of them and
oh for sure
i do think jake's in there and he's the
one who killed oh somebody's in there
right yeah it's gotta be jake right like
unless they created a whole new
character there's not a fourth human is
there
i only know about the three from the
comics
jake steven
mark because they did the personalities
different like moon knight and mr knight
oh they're very different yeah very
different from the comics so i mean for
all we know jake has his own version of
moon knight too that we don't
necessarily know about
that's going to be introduced through
the series like it's a little odd where
we're where they're headed with that so
we'll have to see what they did to
change that yeah
i mean i'm only really aware of
stephen grant and jake locke oh somebody
brings up a good point isaac gump jake
luckily probably got stephen that date
then right
because if we know
mark's married
that's a good point that's actually the
first time i've heard that who is that
more like i'm writing isaac gump
gump
yep isaac gump that's good jake luckily
probably got stephen that date and
that's a very very good point um
very very good point
uh it's likely i guess from what we know
from stephen and from mark steven didn't
get himself to date yeah mark's married
so married and inter-twinkled i doubt
he's out there you know very good get
something very good
that's actually probably very true
that's probably accurate
yeah he's this playboy taxi driver who
can apparently really hurt people
well
in the comics steven grant's the
millionaire and it's like not and he's
the you know like he's the bruce wayne
and he's definitely not missing a
comment yeah comic so who knows but
what's interesting is
felix wouldn't kanchu
know that there's another person because
he's there watching it all the time
originally when we got on it was like
does kanchu have him hidden behind
to
in case
mark starts failing and pulls out him
like that could have been the case here
but then there's the whole if you did
ask this girl out on the date you know
jake's been coming out too like it's not
like he's been hitting away the whole
time he's been coming out and doing
stuff too potentially right and you
think since mark is the main person
because marcus like it's not the deal
you're not supposed to have this guy you
think country would be like what the
hell there's another guy coming out dude
like get your crap together what are you
doing yeah who are these people get your
crap together i also wonder like
because it's not been explained for moon
night the series yet but are they actual
different people or is this actually a
personality disorder that mark specter
has
wait and stephen
is it like are there actually three
personalities
are there actually three identities
or has mark spectre actually just had
this identity disorder
thrown like to the super extreme
i
think they're one and the same
yeah i think what you yeah i think those
two things you just mentioned are the
same like he's got dissociative identity
disorder which
makes these different people come out
yeah it's crazy it's it's pretty intense
it's pretty wild
yeah
alright guys we gotta work but that was
to me the best episode so far um a lot
of fun
i i think a lot of people are really
going to join the next episode um and
then go what the hell
in a good way not in it not a bad way
yeah we'll be here next week like having
a great chat i think with everybody
uh james ayers league of super chat
which personality starts next episode
should be stephen
no it starts
it starts where it left off it starts in
the desert
with
with
steven slash mark unconscious in the
desert and then one of them like just
gets up and i don't remember who it is
can't tell you sorry
but it starts off with none because he's
unconscious
yeah starts off with a violent so there
you go
so all right guys we're heading off uh
let's refrain from super chats because
i'm going to miss them at this point if
you give me one uh thank you to mr
anderson for being an awesome mod uh
forsaking us here at one point in time
too
uh
jonathan cohoon uh thanks for being a
member real quick thanks for being a
member um
rick the third one would be jake lockley
and uh jonathan what accent will jake
have i don't know
i want to say american maybe
because stephen has a british one mark
has an american i want to just say
american maybe it's french maybe it's
arabic
mark is the main
yeah mark is definitely the main guy so
um
but yeah
check out mr anderson's channel if you
have it he uh he started the channel he
just put that link down there
check out chris over cosmic culture i'm
i'm warren
check out warren i haven't i have the
title
cosmic wonder you're here now
at this point everybody knows thanks for
checking
[Laughter]
so yeah yeah uh thanks to any new
members who joined today and look up for
my breakdown in like
six hours
all right guys thank y'all for stopping
by say bye to chris
bye
bye
and
oops nope nope nope
nope go away
all right everybody thank you for
stopping by the stream today love doing
these uh ismail montoya uh episode four
did not have a post credit that i saw so
maybe five and six six probably will you
know marvel doesn't do anything end
anything without having to post credit
but uh i didn't see anything in four so
we'll see
uh
see ya ritwick thanks up bye mr anderson
thanks so much for saying thank you bye
sue um bye everybody appreciate all
stopping by